out of being alone
[Applause]
[Music]
Vanessa Hudgens knows a thing or two
about sneaker knife
and karaoke night
[Music]
The Troop will threaten her fiance MLB
Pro Cole Tucker give their best JLo and
Ja Rule to wedding the 2001 classic I'm
real
[Music]
[Applause]
Vanessa shared the performance on
Instagram her caption because I'm
obsessed with my fiance and we're real
[Music]
girls got pipes but we aren't surprised
Vanessa is not only an actress but a pop
princess with two Studio albums under
her belt I just loved performing like
some people call themselves actresses
some call themselves musicians I call
myself like a performer not to mention
all those jams that had us dancing
during her High School Musical days
[Music]
and it's no coincidence she picked a JLo
song for their sexy serenade the pair
formed a friendship after co-starring in
2018's second act
Here's to Us
working together so many magical moments
I feel so lucky to work with Jen because
she was just one of those people that I
got working with and felt like I had
known her my whole life which does not
always happen I was doing this movie and
all of our girls were like super excited
that Vanessa was in the movie they were
like you're working
but back to baby being her man Cole the
parent got engaged during a February
trip to Paris after two years of dating
what is it about this relationship that
feels different I see you even just like
kind of beaming right now with this huge
smile it's
easy uh we're like the same person very
much the same person but with different
interests so it's cool Vanessa told ET
in April their wedding planning and it's
kind of overwhelming you know it's it's
a slot more than I expected it to be I'm
still the the very beginning the very
Basics I'm still still searching well
it's okay take your time yeah totally
you know yeah I'm getting married that's
all that's all that matters but
thankfully B's besties Sarah Hyland is
showing her the ropes she hit you up for
any advice as far as wedding planning
goes oh she didn't even have to hit me
up I went over
I actually got the book I I legitimately
brought books over I surprised her at
her house like another friend of ours
and like we had balloons and like we
surprised her with like champagne and
balloons and like I brought over all of
my wedding books something tells us
Vanessa and Cole will get the wedding of
their dreams and we're hoping there's
some karaoke involved
[Applause]
[Music]